all right so laura ingraham is taking a
vacation vacation amid the advertiser
boycott and all the outrage that's still
growing it hasn't died down you know
here we are four or five days later
because of this you know unnecessary and
dumb tweet that she sent about david hog
unnecessary and dumb also completely
innocuous in fact let's just you know
just to frame this and in case you're in
case you forget let's just just remind
you what the tweet was what this
offending tweet was and this is the
tweet that has potentially destroyed her
career and has had you know over a dozen
advertisers flee and all these people
coming after and this is the tweet okay
that she sent on march 28th at 11:45
a.m. she the tweet is linking to an
article it says david hog rejected by
four colleges to which he applied and
whines about it dinged by u s-- ding by
UCLA with a 4.1 GPA totally predictable
given acceptance rates that's the tweet
that's the tweet that everyone is people
are you know accusing her she's mocking
a child she was she was ruthlessly
attacking and mocking this child
there's nothing mocking in here except
for the part which he says whines about
it you know she's not even really making
fun of him for as far as i could tell
based on the tweet she's not saying uh
hahaha
this kid didn't make it in the couch
she's saying he was rejected by for
college and he whines about it um which
he has been whining about it I mean
that's both of those things are true he
was rejected by four colleges he was
whining about it we only know that he
was rejected by the colleges because he
was complaining about it publicly you
know in front of the world he was
complaining about it so all she's doing
is pointing that out and now she's got
everyone coming after before I go into
further I just you know one thing I
think I need to admit and address is
that I wrote a piece on Friday saying
that we all need to just ignore
David hog from now on and not talk about
him and here I am two days later three
days later talking about David hog again
and I realize that's kind of
hypocritical but it's not David I don't
want to talk about David hog there's a
there's a greater point here that needs
to be made and unfortunately in order to
make that point it's necessary that I
use David hog as an example okay so
going back to Laura Ingraham she's got
all these advertisers fleeing from her
Expedia TripAdvisor Hulu Office Depot a
bunch of others and Ingram quickly
apologized for this for that you know
this tweet that I just read to you this
is the one she apologized for it she
sent out two two tweets you know
apologizing for it but the left and
David hog and the outraged mob
altogether they're not satisfied they're
saying it's you know wasn't a sincere
apology it's not a sincere enough and so
they haven't called off the dogs they
haven't called off the advertiser
boycott and now David hog is demanding
that she also issue apologies to all the
other people that she's wronged in her
life including LeBron James because she
said something rude about LeBron James a
few a few weeks ago LeBron James has
never asked for an apology but David hog
has it David hog is the is the the
knight in shining armor for LeBron James
saying what apologize to him too
so what we find is that Laura Ingraham
bowed before the pitchfork mob but they
refused to drop their pitchforks they
refused to just let it go even though
she bowed before them she apologized and
yet they're still going why is that I
mean it would seem like they're all
supposedly they're all very upset and
very outraged and so what they would
want her to do usually when you're upset
and outraged at a person for saying
something what you want them to do is
you want them to acknowledge that it was
bad and then apologize for it right and
once they've done that then you just
move on with your life but they're not
doing that why
well because and here's the important
thing we need to understand about
outraged mobs the outraged mob isn't
really outraged okay that's why the the
pitchfork mob what they're doing is
they're putting on an elaborate show
they're putting on a spectacle a charade
that's all they're doing this is a they
sniffed an opportunity Laura Ingraham
gave her them an opportunity which is
why the tweet was so stupid in the first
place and they took it so Ingram's petty
little tweet about david hog it didn't
it didn't hurt anyone who didn't offend
anyone it could've set anyone it didn't
cause any damage to anyone at all least
of all david hog himself who's made it
pretty clear since then that he's
grateful for the opportunity that it
afforded him to cause some damage to
this woman he despises it seems like
he's ecstatic about the tweet he
couldn't be happier about it which goes
back to you know this is my biggest
problem with the tweet is it never
should have been sent because why do you
care about whether or not david hog got
accepted to a college why are you even
commenting on it whether it's offensive
or not whether it hurts anyone's
feelings or not it's not newsworthy
there's no reason to comment on now it
again he's the one who put this out in
in the public he's the one who did that
it was his choice he's put himself in
the public eye and he's been he's
putting this fact about him in the
public eye and complained about it he
has complained about it publicly but
still you know this you know this kid he
wants attention
he desperately wants attention the last
thing we should do is give it to him
david hog did I mean Laura Ingraham did
and that's the mistake but then she
apologizes and they don't leave they
don't leave her alone because this is
how the game works this is how the game
always works and we should understand by
now Laura Ingraham of all people should
understand this is how it works
somebody says or does something uncouth
or supposedly uncouth are slightly
uncouth and the opportunists who reside
on the opposite end of the spectrum from
where
that person from where that offending
person resides and I'm not saying this
is just on the left the right can do it
too but you know the portunities who are
on the opposite end of the spectrum from
where that person resides they seized
upon it whatever the remark was nobody
actually cares nobody's upset nobody's
offended nobody cares but they seize
upon it they grab hold of it and they
just squeeze it dry of every advantage
they possibly can they get every last
drop of advantage out of this out of
this dumb irrelevant statement or tweet
or whatever that nobody in the country
actually cares about this is how it
works and this is also exactly why you
don't apologize to the outraged mob okay
never apologize to them never apologize
to the outraged masses never go in front
of the pitchfork mob and issue an
apology never do it now I do believe
that we should always repent as a
Christian if we do something wrong we
should always repent we should repent to
God if we do something wrong
Jesus is pretty clear about that but
Jesus there's another interesting fact
about Jesus that we overlook I think
sometimes when we read the Gospels um
Jesus who of course never had a reason
to apologize to anybody he also had a
habit of giving the cold shoulder to
disingenuous people he was he was not
going to waste his time with
disingenuous people he wasn't going to
explain or justify himself to those who
were insincere in their request he
wasn't going to be baited he wasn't
going to be used he wasn't going to be
backed into a corner
he wouldn't engage with people who
aren't really interested in engaging and
I think you know that right there just
that aspect of it that's a great lesson
for us we could all learn something from
that if you've committed an offense
that's you know actually very bad and
horrible and you actually have done
damage to a large number of people or
you've hurt a lot of people or you've
scandalized people in some way and that
does happen then in that case sure you
issue a public apology but in that case
you're not bowing before the outraged
mob
you're just you're doing the right thing
because you truly have in that case you
are issuing an apology to a group of
people who you actually have hurt but if
you're just guilty of getting slightly
carried away in your speech or making
some rude but basically harmless comment
or or just saying something kind of dumb
on Twitter if that's all you've done and
the offended masses are coming after you
then then you know and they're acting
like they're acting as if they're not
treating you as if you just made a dumb
comment they're treating you like you
you were just caught skinning puppies or
or beating old ladies or something
that's how they're treating you if
that's what's going on then the worst
thing that you could do is issue a
public apology in that case the public
apology is counterproductive unwise and
cowardly if your if your conscience is
truly stricken by this dumb harmless
thing you said on Twitter then repent to
God for it okay go and repent to God if
you're Catholic go to confession if you
were rude towards some individual person
and you really feel broken up about it
and you feel like it was a terrible
thing to that person then talk to that
person privately but you don't apologize
to the mob or in front of the mob
because they don't deserve it
they are not the aggrieved party they
are not hurt they were not injured by
you they are making these demands
because they want you to submit to them
that's all it's just an opportunity and
they are taking it and now
is gained by offering your submission to
these people who just want power over
you all you've done is vindicated their
their unfair and dishonored dishonest
tactics that's why we have to be very
careful with these public apologies
every time everyone's pretending to be
upset because you're vindicating them
you're vindicating the mob now in um in
Laura Ingraham specific case I think
what she should have done after simply
sending a tweet saying
Oh David hog is doing this thing that
he's doing okay but maybe just delete
the tweet and then and just say nothing
else about it just that's it just delete
it and live your life I'm not suggesting
that she should go out and defend it or
justify it or get into a whole long
debate about David hog and his and his
admissions to colleges and no that's not
what I'm saying you know but she
shouldn't bow she should not have bowed
before the throne and paid homage to
their theatrical ridiculous fake outrage
and you might say that oh well it's the
right thing to do it's always it's
always the right thing to do to issue an
apology but it is most certainly not the
right thing to do in this case it's the
thing people do because they're afraid
and they're bewildered and and and and
they're worried about the backlash it's
cowardice is what it is it's not
something they do because they're driven
by this deep feeling of guilt and regret
there's no reason for a deep feeling of
guilt and regret anyway because her her
her breach of ethics in this case was so
extraordinarily minor and harmless and
here's the thing that according to the
left the only reason she's apologizing
is because of the advertiser boycott
just because she wants to save her
advertisers and they're absolutely right
about that that's why the apology never
should have been offered because it's a
disingenuous
ecology - disingenuous people let me
think about it if you I don't know if
you um if you walk through a door okay
and you and you don't hold the door for
the person behind you that's that's a
rude thing it's a thoughtless thing then
good manners would dictate that after
doing that you can you quickly turn
around and apologize to the person but
if before you even get an apology but
get a chance to apologize if this person
comes bursting through the door and just
starts screaming at you and berating you
and getting in your face and they and
they rile up a mob to come after you and
try to destroy you because of this just
slight breach in manners then what
should you do do you offer the apology
in that case no whereas otherwise you
would have in this case you don't
because who would you even be
apologizing to and what about the mob
they don't care about the door this
isn't about the door they're just happy
for an opportunity to rip somebody to
shreds that's all this is about for them
so deal just because they're reacting
this way now you have to fall to your
face and flagellate yourself in public
because the mob decided to make a
mountain out of a molehill you have to
go along with it and pretend like the
comment was something or or pretend like
the the breach in manners was was more
than it actually was
because they're pretending no and it
doesn't matter anyway there's nothing
you can say to them there's nothing you
can do and so all you can really do is
just move on with your life and be done
with it let them go and find some other
carcass to eat okay let the vultures go
somewhere else just keep just keep
walking through the door and just ignore
them and just go just go do your thing
here's here's I mean it's it's it's kind
of what you're doing is you're you're
cooperating with dishonesty when you bow
to the outraged mob you're caught
because what they're doing as I said
it's all dishonesty nobody actually
cares
nobody's upset nobody in America
actually cares about Laura Ingram's
tweet
it brought no tears to anybody's eyes it
did not cause any pain to anyone's heart
nobody cares nobody not a single person
in America actually cares about the
tweet and in fact most of the people who
are coming after Laura Ingraham they
don't even know what the tweet was they
just heard they saw a headline that oh
she's attacking so that's all they need
it doesn't matter they're saying oh well
thank god this is a chance to go after
Laura Ingraham I hate her
so it's deciced we cannot cooperate with
dishonesty now here's the other thing we
should remember the the outrage doesn't
matter it won't last
do you think that's why now the mob they
really have no power over you except
unfortunately these days they do have
some artificial power because these
companies will once the advertiser start
pulling out well okay that that's a
that's a real thing that causes damage
too but there's no reason once the mob
starts all we're gonna start boycotting
all these advertisers there's no reason
for the advertisers to actually pull
their ads or anything like that because
these people they're not actually
boycotting how many actual now there are
boycott threats in this country five
times a day but how many actual real
boycotts have there been in America
since like the Montgomery bus boycott I
mean how many actual real how many times
have a large group of people actually
changed their consumption habits because
they're upset at a company for this or
that reason there's the Montgomery bus
boycott and then what else do we have
maybe the NFL maybe they maybe the
people fleeing the NFL maybe that's
another example so that's like two
examples I can think of but all of these
other people say oh we're gonna cancel
our Hulu subscriptions because we're
upset about it because they advertise
our Laura Ingraham and she sent a rude
tweet to Dave a dog how many of these
people are actually canceling their
subscription like five of them the vast
majority of the time these boycotts
aren't really boycotts they're just
threats of boycotts there
hashtags of boycotts they're just people
talking about a boycott but there's no
actual boycott so there's no reason to
bow to it and everybody will just move
on that's the other advantage of not
apologizing is that you don't you don't
extend the story anymore
and eventually very quickly people just
move on and they talk about something
else they go look for someone else too
they look for a new outrage of the day
they get bored with this outrage they
look for a new one
there's very little follow-through so
who cares well a lot of people care
apparently but they shouldn't because
outrage is nothing but a game in our
culture and it's a game you can't win so
it's a game that we shouldn't play
that's my point
all right guys have a great day